all right the poll question is posted
the early returns are one year in
certain super bowl win we'll update it
as the show progresses there is the nfc
north once upon a time the nfc central
the black and blue division let's look
at the draft needs with this question
driving the discussion for every team
that we'll be looking at over the next
couple of weeks you cannot leave draft
weekend without addressing
blank let's start with the green bay
packers 13-3 each of the last two years
will not be 13-3 this year because
there's a 17th game 29th overall pick by
virtue of their success last year they
can't leave draft weekend without
addressing what christopher well i mean
they're a team again
you know that's in a good spot there's
no like oh my gosh
huge glaring need it's about really just
going like okay what you know thinking
about the future a little bit and maybe
thinking about
what can actually help us out this year
and get us you know over the top this
year i i to me the thing that i think
jumps out to me are two positions really
that right off the bat yeah wide
receiver is certainly another position i
look at to go yeah why don't we add
another big time weapon to the offensive
side of the ball but i think more than
that
like interior d lyman would probably be
the place i'd still look at mike that to
me
again it's two nfc championship games in
a row where teams just
overpower them i mean again i know green
tampa bay it wasn't just a run show it
was a balanced attack but we saw
and we talked about at the time tampa
bay ran a ran the same run play the
whole game and it was basically like
we're going straight ahead and you're
not going to stop us with leonard
fournette and that's what they did so i
look at it there to go interior d lyman
uh something like that and
there could be the possibility of
you know again christian barb barrymore
from from alabama
you know levi one
i i cannot say his name correctly i
think that they could maybe be on the
board around that time
um but the other guys mike just shelvin
and mcneil could be right up their alley
too
they're big run stuffing big like
pluggers on the inside to stop being run
over that way so that's one position i
think that jumps out to me maybe more
than the rest i don't know if that
happens in the first round but they need
to address that uh regardless
what about the center position corey
linsley is gone i'm looking at an
article from
usa today from middle of march with the
options to replace corey linsley the
three internal options and keeping with
the jeopardy three
jeopardy theme i screwed that up who are
three guys who have never been in my
kitchen guys i have never heard of are
the options to have the most important
position on the offensive line as it
relates to spotting the mic and the play
calls and all the other things that the
center does they have to get a center in
the draft don't they i i i would think
so i would and you know maybe at the end
of the first round you know there could
be a really good one to be had there
mike you know the thing that's always
tough about our job with with offense
alignment is like you're never sure
who's kind of coming up the ranks you
know that that's that's the biggest
issue or who they really believe in you
know so sometimes i'm reluctant to go
down that but yes i mean you're you're
replacing cory linsley the best center
in football it's an offensive system uh
that is very predicated on having a good
center you know we've seen that from
shanahan who sent money in western
richburg and they got alex mack again
and all that type of stuff so it makes
sense and
the guy landon dickerson who we've shown
you know the highlights of behind mack
jones doing cartwheels and and sneaking
up behind him mike he's phenomenal i
mean he is a big time
definite first round center but he's of
course coming off an acl injury but that
could be a guy that certainly could be
thought of in that area and i think he's
special at that to where he he's on the
board late in the first round like that
you might have to take them
one thing they could do is move elton
jenkins who was a pro bowler at left
guard to center but then then they'd
have then they'd have a hole
and left guard uh so that that's you
know it's a zero-sum game when you start
shifting around offensive linemen but
that is one thing that they could do if
they don't come out of the draft with a
guy that they could plug and play at the
center position they're either going to
need one there are they going to want to
guard if they move jenkins over the
in-house options don't look great right
now for the green bay packers um so look
even though they're 13-3 they have needs
every team comes out of a season with
needs except the tampa bay buccaneers
who are returning all 22 starters so
well uh
a 13-3 team for the second year in a row
too
i don't think we ever sit there and look
at them and again this again to me just
speaks to how important rogers is to
them i don't think we look at them and
go well they're that dominant oh they
have that one unit that you just whoa
well watch out for them they don't they
don't have that
you know that that's again to where i
get mad because it just always goes back
to rogers and what he can do there so
we've hit on a few positional needs
there whether it's another interior d
lyman you hit on the center position we
talked about a wide receiver that could
you know make them more explosive or
dangerous middle linebacker could be
another one that could look at they've
had an issue filling that spot the last
two years there might be a good one
there at the end of the first round mike
so uh they got some options they might
be in one of those spots to where they
could just go best player available that
really fits our team and needs that way
another year with a receiver rich draft
remember last year no receivers taken by
the packers at all in the draft if
you're aaron rodgers and they don't take
a receiver this year by the end of round
four
one to ten
what is your level of pissed off just
over that oh i i mean you gotta be like
you're boiling you're fuming you're
right you're a nine i mean you're in the
you're definitely in the nines if they
do that again it's just
i don't understand it nobody's had less
support in the receiving room out of
like the great quarterbacks of all time
it's up there with any of them as far as
the least amount of support around him
and making guys that are
you know average look good or good look
great or below average look like they're
slightly above average nobody's been
better at that in their career than
aaron rodgers and yeah i i mean
i i i am one that certainly sits here
and thinks they need they need one more
go-to guy like we've talked about and
any great offense you really look at
there's three elements that are like
whoa
we gotta stop them they have three
different things that make them special
and green bay certainly doesn't have
that but you go through the you know go
through time with great offenses that's
what they had and green bays usually
only has two
last time they took a receiver in round
one or two was devonte adams in 2014 no
receivers taken the last two years and
you know a lot of potential story ideas
pass across my computer screen or my
cell phone device and i saw something
recently where someone was suggesting
marquez valdez scantling could be traded
what trade
what because the receiver room is so
stocked that's why you would trade him i
i just i i don't get it chris um you you
they don't have enough help for aaron
rodgers as it is and maybe they've got
some plan on draft day that we don't
know about to really maybe they're going
to do the reverse of last year and every
pick is going to be a receiver that
would be the ultimate passive aggressive
move for the packers to make every pick
in this draft a receiver but there's
definitely plenty of good receivers
seems like every year we're gonna have
plenty of good receivers because there's
plenty of quarterbacks throwing the ball
and plenty of guys catching the ball at
the college level all right detroit
lions seventh overall pick in the draft
uh chris they can't leave draft weekend
without what i would say more than
anything i just look at them and i'd go
offensive line would probably be the
number one thing i'd look at you know
they're another team that middle
linebacker is is in that conversation a
little bit
you know maybe secondary help something
like that but i think the one that jumps
out to me more than anything is
offensive line you know i i think of it
for for two reasons one of course hey i
think there's a real need on the unit
uh as far as just improvement that way
but two i just look at them too
you know and go wait it's dan campbell
right i mean it's anthony lynn we know
they want to get back into like
physicality running the football dan
campbell came from new orleans which has
always had this big hulking offensive
line
and i think with the style of football
they probably want to play to me i would
think with one of those two first picks
o lyman
is certainly gonna be a position that
they are evaluating definitely and mike
i don't know i mean
you know sitting there at seven
they could certainly be a team that does
trade down too according to how things
you know fall out but but they're
interesting and i don't know do you
think they'd go quarterback mike a lot
of people think they might go justin
fields at seven
and the the thing that i'm fascinated by
is the the ohio state magnate yeah right
chris spielman if justin fields is there
at number seven will he be able to
resist the fact that fields is a
columbus guy
buckeye will that be a factor
can he can he
set that aside and just make the
evaluation because they have jared goff
for a couple of years they need a
developmental quarterback but they also
need receivers they need a number one
receiver that's what they got to come
out of this weekend with when you
consider the free agent losses and i'm
looking at the receiving core right now
geronimo allison victor bolden quentin
cephas tom kennedy rashad perriman
damian ratley khalif freeman tyrell
williams there's not a number one
receiver on the roster chris no and you
know they're in a bad spot
behind seven they're not going to get
the two guys right right right they may
get the other alabama guy not devonta
smith or them or they may get devonta
smith they waddle may go before smith
they could fall into smith now the
question is would they regard a 5 11 170
pound guy as a kneecap biter that's a
different issue and let me just deviate
to that for a second because we've
talked a lot recently about how the
patriots will let character overcome
everything else i can't help but wonder
whether or not the lions are going to
put too much stock on the roughneck
factor the guy who fits
the guy that dan campbell
described back in january and are they
trying to scout for badasses regardless
of
technique talent speed etc are they just
looking to draft badass after badass
that they can put onto that roster and
have that group of guys that campbell
seems to want so badly yeah no i mean i
i think there's definitely going to be a
wanting of that type of guy there's no
doubt now the wide receiver thing you
bring up i mean like i'm with you all
the way
i would think there's going to be a good
one to get at the top of the top of the
seventh if they really want it you know
but maybe that's one of those things too
where listen mike i think
chase
and smith in my eyes are
in a class of their own as far as the
top two receivers they're legitimate top
10 picks you know waddles real good
i don't think i i think he goes
somewhere between 10 and 20 is what i
would say and that to me is where i go
maybe detroit decides it
does decide to trade down or do
something like that with those two guys
being going but they're in a very
interesting position because they could
probably get you know an offensive
lineman
that they really like whether that's a
rashaan slater from northwestern the
christian darasaw from virginia tech
those are some of the top tackles in the
draft they certainly use you know and
maybe they do that at seven maybe penny
sewell's there at seven that i mean
i'm not gonna be mad at them for going
that route you know wide receiver
i don't know waddle at seven is a little
bit of an overreach but the big thing is
the justin fields angle like you brought
up and the ohio state connection and
everything that way
um i i i i'm intrigued by that i don't
envision them doing that i think they're
gonna stay pat with jared goff i have no
inside info of that i just feel that's
the way the organization is going at
least for right now um but this is a
team that's that's totally trying to
rebuild themselves well and and look
this this is a year where given where
they are at number seven
um and given all the other quarterbacks
are expected to go in the first few
picks it's just not this is not a good
year to be trying to get a quarterback
at the top of round one and chances are
next year
they'll they'll be in position again
maybe better than seven
to get a quarterback if that's what they
want to do you mentioned sewell as an
option and this one is going to be
fascinating to me chris because
how will the lion's brain trust and
we're not quite sure who's got the
biggest spoon in the stew between dan
campbell brad holmes chris spielman and
rod wood
how will they view
a guy who opted out
is the guy who opted out a kneecap biter
or not a kneecap biter kneecap biters
don't care about the virus and again
that that's not a mindset i agree with
but
we can't discount the reality that
there's going to be some people in these
draft rooms saying we're going to hold
it against the guy who opted out does he
love football yeah you don't love
football if you love your family enough
to keep them away from the virus or
yourself from having heart complications
or other issues on something we don't
know all that well enough about when
we're making the decision i i just hey
look my reaction is any team that's
going to do that they they deserve what
they get if they pass on a guy who could
be a great player yeah you know you got
to be careful and how you judge this
situation certainly i mean you know
first off you know you better know all
the circumstances what surrounds these
players why they opted out you know and
of course go back to like something
caleb barley talked about with me with
the information we had at that time yeah
things looked exactly more dangerous and
more dire
so if they're looking for for kneecap
biters and eaters and all those type of
things listen all they got to do is turn
on like the the film with penny sewell
because he will bite your knees and and
legs and anything else and i mean that
in a respectful way because he plays
tough and nasty and he's awesome to
watch uh i just i don't know i guess in
my heart of hearts i think the bengals
will end up taking him to pick number
five
all right we're continuing with the nfc
north draft needs minnesota vikings 14th
overall pick chris the vikings they also
don't have a second round pick they've
got two in the third four in the fourth
they cannot leave draft weekend without
what
you know i mean this they already have
that they already have the ones they got
the horn i think this one's an easy one
as far as just like when you boil it
down to one position that they really
need
it i it's edge guy a pass rusher
somebody in that that that range
somebody as far as that guy coming off
the edge whether that's jalen phillips
from the university of miami or quitting
pay from michigan but i think it's it's
that type of player certainly i do i
mean you know you got some young corners
in the secondary you still got harrison
smith at safety you know your
linebackers are pretty good i mean
o-line is is probably something
certainly mike as a fan you'd probably
sit there and go yeah we could probably
use an upgrade there
wide receivers you're okay running backs
you're okay i mean it's not totally bad
there in minnesota i think pass rusher
is is the big thing for mike zimmer in
that defense
yeah i think pass rusher is the key
they've addressed the corner position
aggressively in free agency anthony
smith has gone from the back end anthony
harrison excuse me from the back and
harrison smith is still there it's kind
of tough when one's anthony harrison the
other one's harrison smith you're gonna
mash it together and inadvertently name
the guy who played safety for jesus you
know your own team more than a decade
ago
anthony smith the guy who got brady all
riled up by guaranteeing a win by the
steelers over the patriots in the 2007
season but anthony harris has gone not
that he was great last year there's a
reason why they didn't keep him but you
need help there i'd say later rounds
pass rushers they have to they have and
they've done a good job of drafting and
developing
non-star pass rushers yeah that's one of
the areas where the vikings have had a
strength in recent years but this past
year not good and they don't know what's
up with the neil hunter does he want to
be there how can you trade him when he's
got to prove that he's healthy after
last year's neck problem that kept him
out the full season but i agree with you
pass rusher is key left tackle they're
likely to bump ezra cleveland out to
replace riley reef but then you have a
hole at guard but uh they've got they've
got plenty of things they they need to
do although last week you know when you
were talking to caleb farley yeah and
talking about caleb farley if he would
slip to 14 i just i curious to see what
mike zimmer would do if farley's board
mike mike to me and i'm glad you brought
that up because i was going to bring
this up anyways i think it's this is to
me one of the the great things about
this draft just to get off the team
subject a little bit but
there's four guys mike on this draft
that i would look at and go
these are top 20 picks in the nfl draft
but they all have like an asterisk or
you know an issue next to their name
caleb farley opted out back surgery
jalen phillips you know the michigan the
best pass rusher in the draft he has
concussion and retired from football for
a year you know there's a left tackle
from stanford walker little mike i mean
slam dunk first rounder that kind of
player and the receiver rondell moore
from purdue who's been hurt the last two
years is a freak show he was one of the
best receivers in college football as a
true freshman that to me is going to be
one of the intriguing things about the
draft is there's four really talented
guys that might be on the board for the
best teams in football late in the first
round because there's a little bit of an
injury history there i think it's one of
the wild cards of the draft in my
opinion
all right give me one thing the bears
need draft weekend i i think that does
go o-line i think when i look at the
them more than anything you know tackle
probably more than anything at 20 there
there should be a good one left over uh
whether that's a tevin jenkins or my
oklahoma state or something like that
but come on you know the bears have had
issues for the last few years up front
they don't open a lot of holes they're
not the great but
greatest pass protecting team i think
that's where it starts for them
and guys who can make a difference right
away yes they need a developmental
quarterback but not if the gm and the
head coach aren't going to be there to
develop the quarterback they need impact
players at areas of need kyle fuller's
gone at corner it was a cap move that's
another corner you can plug right in you
need that you need guys that can play
now make the team better get to the
playoffs again secure the future for
ryan pace and matt nagy that's job
number one even though they definitely
need a quarterback they're not far off
21 season
um well no they're not and and they they
they made it to the playoffs they've
been in the playoffs two of the last
three years they did amazing playoffs
two of the last three years and
and one of the hottest seats in football
going into 2021 is for gm ryan pace and
coach matt neg and they've been to the
playoffs to the last three years
i know amazing but that's what happens
when you pass on patrick mahomes and
take mitch trubisky instead in 2017 even
though nagi wasn't there for them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports